we have a voicemail number that number
is two one nine two david p you can call
that number anytime you want here is a
question that came in overnight about
what will happen when jimmy carter
passes away take a listen to this hey
David I just saw George HW Bush a
national day of mourning and we closed
post offices and I think most federal
agencies didn't require their employees
to work that day either
what is interesting if this happens the
Jimmy Carter god forbid and if he should
pass away do you think there will be a
national day of mourning for Jimmy
Carter as well yeah a bunch of people
wrote in about this saying you know
normally you don't necessarily shut down
the post office when a president dies
the stock market was also shut down a
lot of federal offices were also shut
down will the same thing happen when
Jimmy Carter some day if Jimmy Carter
passes away a very long time from now
obviously I hope the answer is yes Pat I
hope that this is now if this is what
we're doing whether we agree or disagree
that it's what we should do it should
happen for all presidents and I hope
that the same I was surprised actually I
went to the post office yesterday to
mail a couple of things and came across
a post office that was closed in
observance of George HW Bush's funeral
if we're doing it for George HW Bush it
should happen for all presidents
regardless of political party and
hopefully it will although these are
sort of one-on-one decisions that want
individual decisions that are made based
on whoever is in the White House and the
administration at the time of a past
presidents passing so there's no
guarantee that all passings will be
handled in the exact same way hard to
argue against keeping consistent I guess
I mean the last president who passed
away was Gerald Ford and that was some
12 years ago so it's just kind of been a
while since we've had to go through an
experience like this but I'd imagine
they're gonna do the exact same thing
for Jimmy Carter I don't see why not I
hope so I hope that they do on today's
bonus
pat is now regularly fighting with
people what am I talking about we will
discuss it on the bonus show that's
going to tell us on all about it what
kind of fights is he getting into we
will also talk about the first
commercial Robo taxi autonomous vehicle
service in Arizona you can now get
picked up by way mo one which is the
first commercial Robo taxi that is live
and available I also want to talk about
these phrases like bring home the bacon
and beating a dead horse that PETA
People for the Ethical Treatment of
Animals are saying are equivalent to
racism and homophobia hint I don't agree
but we will talk about that and more on
today's bonus show get access to the
bonus show instantly by becoming a
member at WWE pakman.com or by becoming
a patron at patreon.com slash david
pakman show thanks to everybody who has
signed up over the last 24 hours it's
been solid appreciate every single one
of you and we will see you on the bonus
show